I have something really good to show you
Dan Goldman is a new Congressman on the
Democratic side this guy is a major
asset to the Democratic party he
confronted Republican Congressman Jim
Jordan during this weaponization
committee Republicans when they took
control of the house created all of
these bogus committees we're going to do
a Twitter committee to look into big
Tech we're going to do a weaponization
of government committee to look into the
FBI and all these different things Jim
Jordan during these hearings has
offhandedly been mentioning that there
are dozens of whistleblowers who are who
know the truth about what went on
uh Dan Goldman who's an attorney
actually confronts Jim Jordan and says
are there notes about these
whistleblowers when will you give us the
information about these whistleblowers
and look at how quickly and easily Jim
Jordan is Tangled Up into a rhetorical
pretzel this is so devastating the way
that Goldman schools Jordan here is
brutal and I don't know why Jordan would
have expected anything else from a
former Federal prosecutor an actual
prosecutor let's Dive Right into this
this is gold on providing that to the
minority the point is it wasn't special
so much it became the norm with that the
chair down you can have a point of order
um has there been a lot of mention of uh
information and testimony that you all
have received from whistleblowers when
are you planning on providing that to
the minority you could have been for the
very first deposition or excuse me
transcribed interview The Whistleblower
I was there when he testified on Tuesday
okay that's fine I assume you'll turn
those over but what about you you talk
about about dozens of whistleblowers
when are we going to get that
information remember dozens means at
least 24. you're talking about at least
two dozen when they testify when when we
work with I'll work with the ranking
Emerald on that if you don't have any uh
transcriptions of their interviews we
have the first one and we have the
dozens who come and talk to our office
they talk to your office privately I
talk to Republican staff right
and they're not transcribed no notes no
nothing first one happened Tuesday no no
I'm not talking about the first one see
the next one happens tomorrow the third
one happens next Wednesday and we'll
continue to do that you just said dozens
are you do have notes from those or
they're just talking to you at the rate
at which Jordan's saying they're going
to be talking to people you're talking
about a year before you hear from dozens
chairman isn't isn't that how
whistleblowers typically work well it's
how they're supposed to work it's not
how they worked in the in the
impeachment that Mr Goldman was a part
of when that goes into ad hominem's Mr
ship said he didn't have contact with
that whistleblower it worked exactly
appropriately until Mrs would not allow
we're doing it the way we were supposed
to do it Mr Goldman no you're supposed
to turn it over to the minority when
they when they have when they come and
testify you'll have access to the
transcript like and understand what
Jordan so the point that Goldman is
making is inquiring as to whether these
dozens of whistleblowers really exists
because they keep being mentioned in
passing and what Jordan wants to focus
on is you'll hear from them when they
come and testify but of course
both sides have people on the committee
both sides get to ask Witnesses
questions in order for the Democrats on
the committee to be ready to
meaningfully inquire of these supposedly
dozens of whistleblowers they need
information about them they don't even
have names understand that and that'll
that'll be mentioned in a moment Jim
Jordan keeps saying well you'll get
information when they testify and
Goldman says but where are the notes
where's the information so we can
prepare the implication of course is
these dozens of whistleblowers simply
don't exist everyone on the committee
will you mean your staff is not going to
turn it over to our staff we're just in
the dark now when the transcript is done
you will get the transcript I mean it
for the dozens of whistleblowers you
have already talked to that came to talk
to your staff supposedly yeah what do
you want me to turn over there
Jim are the whistleblowers in the room
with us right now can you see them here
their names
notes did anyone take notes we'll I'll
be happy to talk with the ranking member
on how we handle uh that information
thank you all I'm telling you is we will
schedule each for a deposition and we're
that is not what he's talking about
doing that you didn't show up for the
first one uh but you could have been
there with that I didn't know about it
the chair now recognized
Goldman's a really valuable asset in
this political climate he is
straightforward in his approach but he
maintains a professional demeanor he has
extraordinary attention to detail he
leaves no stone unturned in his lines of
inquiry and we all know the implication
here which is there is no evidence that
these dozens of whistleblowers exist
were aware of one supposed whistleblower
remember also that the right has a
history over the last let's call it in
the Trump era in the last six plus years
the right as a history of presenting
someone as a whistleblower when they're
not really blowing the whistle about
anything like I could call myself a
whistleblower but then if I show up and
I basically say here's the terms of
service from Twitter and they were being
followed I'm not really blowing the
whistle on anything right you can call
me a whistleblower you can turn on
bright lights and put makeup on me and
ask me questions and say I'm a hero and
put me on Hannity or whatever but I'm
not really blowing the whistle unless
I'm actually blowing the whistle and so
do these 24 or 36 I don't know how many
dozens Jim maybe I don't know if Jim
Jordan knows what the word dozens mean
but
if these dozens of whistleblowers exist
is a real question and if people exist
who are going to be called
whistleblowers there's a real question
as whether as to whether they are
blowing the whistle about anything so
Jim Jordan is not the type of guy that
can go up against Dan Goldman Jim Jordan
should be embarrassed in this way at
every single hearing because he is a
joke and it is humiliating we'll have
the clips I played for you here on our
Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show and on our Youtube
channel search YouTube for David
Pacman's show you'll find it easily